good evening ladies and gentlemen you
can't do like clapping we've got a lot
to talk about this evening and a lot of
films we've got to talk about - a lot of
years you've also directed some of them
you've also produced some of them
considering that you have all those
roles are you still at heart a writer
yes that is your that is your primary
totally so my passport sets that's what
that is what your first ones yes that's
great well it's not the thing that gives
you the most pleasure I do like the
writing the best I think I like editing
movies also you know it's the actual
making of them that's hard but you know
the writing is it's really where it all
happens and then the directing I find is
just executing the writing it's really
why I became a director honestly it
wasn't it really started out of just
protecting the screenplay I'm quite
surprised that you don't see more
writers kind of taking control to make
sure that their work is the thing you're
mostly writers here right I think the
writers personality is probably better
suited to directing than producing and
you know I think Studios like producers
that they feel are sort of in their
world a little bit you know which
writers generally aren't friends with
studio executives and management kind of
jobs so I think writing and directing
goes perfectly together how do you run
yourself in if you have all of those
three kind of key creative roles who
turns around cuz normally why do you
need to be reined in I'm well do you do
you need to be I don't think so no not
really
do you never have anxiety about I mean
are you so confident as a writer and
these are many different areas we're
talking about so do you need to be
reined and suggests out of bounds in
some way and I know you just said it
loosely but I mean it does suggest like
somehow the message is getting lost
which is not it no it's all about get
the page on the screen I mean if I'm at
the point where I'm making a movie I am
confident about it I'm not gonna put
myself out there and do it it's another
year of my life I have to be the one
that's confident about it I have to be
the most confident about it okay so what
about the other people that you work
with their normal writers people will
give you notes who does that for you
well I've gone to friends for notes
I remember on
something's gotta give I thought I was
done it was a year of my life it was 250
pages I finally got down to 125 pages
and you know who James L Brooks is for
those of you don't know you know you
want a lot of Oscars for terms of
endearment but he made broadcast news
and lots of terrific movies so I've
known him for years so I said Cobb will
you read my script I'm just gonna hand
it and just tell me if there's anything
I've missed you know it and he read the
script he came over to my house and he
stayed about six hours and we sort of
went through it
he had such good ideas really good ideas
he said he's an interesting note giver
because he gives you absolutely no
solutions to anything but he says is
there something in the idea of you know
like that kind of a question that kind
of a conversation and then I spend
another month just based on those six
hours he was at my house so at the
beginning who student well like in the
beginning beginning my experience in the
movie business is that they don't want
to give you too many notes they really
want you to figure it out so that's
where the confidence thing I think helps
I think if you show up like I would
never take a pen to a meeting for
example I'm not there to take notes I'm
there to have a conversation if we talk
about something that comes up but I
think if you show up with your little
pad and you're you know you're they die
my personal philosophy honestly is I
think they want you to feel really
confident they want you to be able to
defend what you've done
I wouldn't hand anything until it works
and typically how long does that take do
you is it a long time is there a
difference in the you know some films
just come to you and the scripture out
I'll take a long time what's a long time
here yeah it's very strange reading a
kind of whole range of reviews and
comments about movies that you've made
uh-huh I wonder if you feel critic proof
because your films do a really strange
things where a lot of them that I
thought they are my critic proof yet
critic proof so they get cyber center
criticisms yeah then they go on to make
an absolute fortune at the box office
and break all sorts of records and then
they get to scoop up awards got on
delayed nominations bath I mean I mean
I'm in the midst of it now I'm
you know my film came out yesterday I'm
D at home and you know the reviews I've
read a couple and then I stopped reading
them because every time I forget I also
think oh no they're gonna embrace me now
I'm older I've proven myself time and
again yeah forget it but do you do you
care I do care I wish I didn't care I
wish I was bigger but you know
unfortunately like all human beings I
remember the bad ones yeah they can you
get major sense of satisfaction they you
know as the I've had this conversation
at dinner parties with people that are
world famous you know actors and we've
all talked about it they can all quote
the worst things ever said about them
and then somebody will say do you
remember the good things and not one of
us or remember it yeah okay well let's
go back and look at the good things okay
um there are a lot of them but let's
start with your first good thing okay
which we knew about which was Private
Benjamin okay
just tell us this was not the first
screenplay you wrote I sort of wrote a
practice script okay you know I wrote
something that I actually never showed
anybody did you how did you get to the
point of writing you'll first even your
first practice script a friend of mine
was a TV writer and he knew I had just
left this job to become a writer and he
asked me if I wanted to go straight a
script for him which means I wrote it
and he put his name on it and yeah I
said yeah that was fun so I did that and
then he really liked the way it turned
out and then we wrote something together
and this time I got to put my name on it
but he still made all the money and then
these are films that got made no these
are our TV shows that never happened it
was me I was so young I was a beginning
you know I was like I was felt I was a
writer I was starting and then while he
and I were writing together he was my
the man I lived with man who I then
married he it was his best friend so
when he would come home at night he was
a writer the three of us would have
dinner all the time so it was kind of
like a fun write early kind of life and
then I had a job I had a job I had an
idea for a movie for Private Benjamin
and I presented it to them one night
after when Charles came home and Harvey
Miller and I were working and I said so
I had this idea what do you think of
this you think this could be a movie
that's how it happened so I told the two
of them the idea Charles was an actual
screenwriter Harvey had
we've been in the army and I was an
actual woman so between the three of us
we hammered out that script it was the
most fun writing ever that was the most
fun did you did you feel like you were
kind of pushing Bulls down to make that
not aware of that no no it was that not
the kind of thing I mean this is not was
in our did get in our rating okay one
thing you must have noticed the
differently which is the fact that you
had you got greenlit and became very
successful with a film which had a
female lead and no male lead that was
yes we were aware of that and it was
really hard to get the movie made by the
way every single studio in Hollywood
read it and passed on it nobody even met
with us it was really hard as a matter
of fact one studio head called Goldie
and said if you make this movie it's a
career ender and she said I don't think
so I don't agree and then finally
honestly we got it made at the last
moment the very last person to read it
it said okay and do you remember it
changing much in the process was it
something I said
do you remember it changing the process
as you went through the process of you
know but originally writing it and then
going through all the fights with the
street mano fights but you know being
rejected rejected I mean did you change
it at all did you stick with your
original stuck with it okay yeah one
studio came to us they said we'll make
it
urban a movie called urban cowboy with
John Travolta had just come out Debra
Winger and so that was a big hit so he
said if you make her from Texas we could
do this well maybe we make this with you
so I looked at the two boys I was
writing with I said you're counting on
me to write the girl I don't know
anything about Texas never been there I
don't know how to write a girl from
Texas we can't and they didn't want to
do it either by the way but that was not
that's those kind of things happen or
used to happen mm-hmm does that suggest
that you always write about what you
know exactly best oh for me you know
yeah and you never bring you in elements
that no of course I don't know anything
about the army I didn't know it this new
movie takes place in a startup I knew
nothing about a startup there's all
kinds of things I don't know that I'll
learn about but the the essence of the
character has to be what
Sam I understood her upbringing I put
her placed her exactly in the
neighborhood I came from and then when
you finally got I know you didn't direct
it but when you when it came yes good
did you did you recognize what you'd
written is it is it very close to oh
yeah but just reproduced it yeah yeah we
wouldn't sell it we were new and young
and we just said it's for sale with us
as producers and they sort of okay we're
stuck with them but they were stuck with
us and then you you were you know lauded
and baited and then it wasn't the Oscar
no oh yes it was nominated that's what
I'm worried about we don't want it yeah
no we didn't but what did that was a sad
night I was sitting in the front row at
the Academy Awards and Pierre Finch
presented the award and he was standing
right in front of me with the envelope
and there was a giant light on him and I
read right through the envelope and I
didn't want to say anything to Harvey or
Charles because I just wanted them to
have their moment but I saw there were
not three names on it
god you could put that a film that was
horrible but what impact did that have
so Oscar nomination was huge but and and
this was just your debut screen yeah so
did that then suddenly button you find
all those doors opening and people
taking notice obviously was a great
thing and the picture did really well
which is great like how I call him
pictures so the picture did well so that
was great but the next movie we did was
a rather small little kind of
independent movie hmm I'm interested in
what you how you start your screenplays
and particularly I wonder if you start
with a character starting is really hard
I find the beginning is really hard okay
the hardest part once you get in there
it's just so much better but the
beginning so hard I'll do anything to
avoid the beginning okay we've got some
of your characters here this is a kind
of okay quick visual reminder yeah um
tell us about your your writer character
is she you you were uh you're the Oh
something's gotta give character well
when she when she won the Golden Globe
she got up on the stage and said well
when I play Nancy
I always sorrow I hadn't thought of it
that way but you did
she's the closest to me I would say but
how does be on the same job you know and
similar traits and we were both divorced
and we both had friendly relationships
with our ex-husband hmm and we both met
somebody new so there was all that but
none of the circumstances are the same
okay
and how much do you know about your
characters backstory Oh a lot in do you
write that I yeah I do
I totally do biographies more or less I
really figure out who they were who
their parents were how they were treated
where they went to school yeah how did
they get to be the person they are I
can't just start writing or they're just
gonna sound like me more like me even
than she does and then is it different
obviously we you know we struggled
really to find a picture of a man why
well what about now we'll come back to
though but but with what is what we've
just used him as a representative man
and I'm just a second him Steve yeah
yeah but um I mean Jack I think is
different because the film Jack's when
Jack is in your film with Diane she's
the lead steve is the lead in in father
of the bride and I wondered if it's you
say that I mean I would say it's a
two-hander something's gotta give
is it to handler that's funny I think of
it as being her that's that's what I was
looking at talk to Jack okay but but but
very but very definitely father of the
bride is is Steve's film and does that
when y'all think it is called father of
the bride yeah it's a clue
that's when you're I know it's like
different because you were basing it on
an on a you know yeah but do you think
differently when you're building up a
character when you're writing the
character do you think differently when
you look at writing the character of a
man that than you would about any of the
other women that you write I don't give
them less attention no I work equally
hard okay I'm their character do you
find it as easy to I mean if you want a
match oh I love writing a man oh yeah oh
for sure for sure for sure yes I mean
like Jack and I figured out the art in
his characters house and I remember
doing that with him oh no I worked the
same I put the same work into every
character but it's interesting though if
you wouldn't make Judy from Texas
because you don't know Texas you know I
didn't know that
but you feel comfortable writing from a
from as if you're a man well that's a
good point but but I mean I've known men
my whole life I've never been in Texas
right never been one but I I know them
better than I know Texas okay so this is
you still writing and producing at which
point did you do you think about actors
at that point well Steve asked us to do
this movie with him so we had him from
well he had asked we had him from the
Reno so was he before Steve Martin yeah
and I'm a huge Steve Martin fan still so
that was an honor really mm-hmm so right
from the outset you knew you had yeah
you were writing for him how much which
is a gift yeah it's a gift because you
know you're writing for Steve Martin so
you know you can be funny and you can be
loose and you can do all these twists
and turns in the scene of and he has
such a very specific comic delivery not
a particular way of talking and how how
did you get that into your head when you
were writing well it's not so much to
get his delivery in my head just sort of
get just make it funny enough you know
you
I felt I remember feeling why it was a
little bit of pressure to be as good as
a Steve Martin comedy yeah but it was so
freeing to because you didn't have to
worry what if I get someone who can't do
this and how I don't have to temper
anything yeah when you don't have big
personalities involved at year that
you're you've got your kind of sights on
right do you is that is that harder to
just write general parts or do you then
just have fun with you know people
looking and saying I mean how much do
you visualize what people look like when
you write how much do you visualize the
patterns of speech well if I don't have
an actor in mind I try not to get too
specific with it you know it's it's hard
to explain how you see I'm sure
novelists do the same thing they picture
something they have some image of the
character but you can't I can't put
Robert De Niro's face on it if I don't
have Robert De Niro okay do you ever
think you do casting it not let you cast
but you rock you know when you're
casting as you write do you do it
against type ever almost always yeah in
my opinion can you think of specific
examples where you've done that really
dramatically
while this movie what you haven't seen
you at the intern opens next Friday ha
ha ha Robert De Niro plays the nicest
guy he's really he's really a very
centered calm patient non-threatening
person totally against type because in
every comedy he's in he's sort of
trading on his threatening stuffed it
and people know him from scary he'll do
you know in the Fockers movie you know
he'll put Ben Stiller in a lie-detector
machine you know he's not nuts in my
movie at all so I think that's very much
against time and then also casting
casting people like Mel Gibson and what
women want you know pretty macho guy
becomes a feminist jack falls in love
with a woman his age hello I'd say this
is my trademark now that I'm just gonna
back to the point about it being a
remake ditch this one father of the
bride yeah yeah did you go back to the
original script or the yes had a copy of
the scrub okay did you look at the film
did you know of course yes looked at the
movie it wasn't it wasn't so much a
comedy it was kind of a light mm-hmm
hearted you know we we because we were
making a Steve Martin movie we wanted to
make it more comedic just really
definitely funnier stuff all throughout
and Spencer Tracy and Steve Martin have
very different strengths so we didn't
you know I think if if we were given do
you want to do a remake a father of the
bride we maybe would have made it a
little straighter like the steep like
the Spencer Tracy version but once we
have Steve Martin then you know you just
cut loose more and it's the most fun
mm-hmm um let's move on to your next
remake or your own okay the other remake
which was Parent Trap right which of
course is the first film that you
directed yes do you do exactly the same
process or did you has you learnt
lessons on father that you then well
there's lesson in a remake I'm sure it's
same is in adapting a book is don't go
too far off of it right modernize it but
don't change it radically because what's
the point making a make an original
movie then if you're gonna remake a
classic it has to you know I met you
know of course you know what Hayley
Mills is we had a royal premiere for the
movie
and they said to all of us I was there
Dennis Quaid was there Natasha
Richardson was there and they told us to
all come to rehearsal at 2:00 in the
afternoon to figure out how to meet the
Queen and where you're supposed to stand
on all this test only two people showed
up me and Hayley Mills nobody else
showed up success Hayley was invited
because of this so so it's just the two
of us and they ran us through the whole
thing and I introduced myself I said I'm
you know I'm the director of the movie
and she kind of look at me and like and
then after the screening that night she
came up to me and she hugged me and she
said I was so afraid to see this movie
she said but you didn't ruin it I said
thank you I liked it as much as our
version you know which is the best
compliment I could get because I was 10
when Parent Trap came out I loved Parent
Trap
loved it loved 11 it's very girl
empowering movie and yep because the
children and the daughter the two girls
make everything happen they have total
control of the destiny of their family
so I had a ten-year-old I was made these
two movies for Disney the father of the
bride movies and I said to them would
you ever consider remaking Parent Trap
and they said yeah what did directing do
to you as a writer it didn't really need
to see I had been very hands-on as a
producer because my ex-husband had
directed all these movies you made so I
was always there very present always in
front of the monitor so it wasn't like
my first time seeing my words come to
life or anything you know I was 48 by
the first time I directed and I've been
making movies for close to 20 years so
it didn't it would normally if I just
been a writer and then became a director
but since I made all those other movies
it was not a horrible transition okay
um it didn't we could talk it was
interesting so because you then your
next step was to not write at all was to
direct women were really more I wasn't
credited but I wrote the script okay
there's a funny difficult situation okay
okay okay
well having done having directed and
then in that case going back to writing
yeah we want did it make it didn't make
you do anything differently No
that's interesting nothing at all no
because you've been so involved yeah
because I already was making movies okay
I wasn't a writer at home that first got
to be on a set okay you do get smarter
with every movie mmm
certainly I've read quite a lot about
you as a you you're quite a big mood
board user and I'm not quite sure
whether that's because you're a director
or that's you at the point of writing I
don't know if we can have a look you're
a big Pinterest fan now I see oh this is
my pinch or you want Pinterest anybody
yeah I know this is specifically about
the intern each character has a page you
know sometimes the images are there for
the actors to soak up here's the thing
as a writer as you know you've been
thinking about it and thinking about it
thinking about it now all these people
are gonna come in and they're gonna
design the sets figure out your wardrobe
actors are gonna say the lines the more
I can get them into my head the better
time it's gonna be for everybody have
you done this with all the movies or
doesn't house one you face I guess it
was pretty sweet how'd you do mood
boards and very big bulletin boards in
my office with all kinds of it's a
matter of fact in the holiday I seen
this little cottage and Vogue magazine
they've done a fashion shoot out in
somewhere Cotswolds I think and and like
this cottage just stuck in my mind and I
had it by my computer when I was writing
and then it went up on my bulletin board
and then they found it I remember they
called me we found it it's impossible to
get to possible we connect to it
so we sort of copied it yeah you know
but that cottage everybody knew what we
were looking for how much of your
interiors do you script
I mean separation interiors you don't
describe what I do is I do little maps
of floor plans when I'm writing because
if I'm writing she comes out of her
bedroom and goes into the kitchen I have
to know how she gets there am I just
gonna cut to exiting one door and
entering I can do that but I need to
know how she got there did she go down a
flight of stairs did she want
so I do a floor plan which we then build
someone makes it good like there's a
scene and something's got to get I don't
know if you remember where they're doing
like instant messaging each other and
they just say you want to meet in the
kitchen
comes out of his room and she comes out
of her room so I had to have a house
built where they could do that it's so
they weren't both coming out at the same
side you know they had to be opposite
side so we built that whole house that
whole floor plan is based on that moment
that's amazing
and do you with other describing how
descriptive of your scripts anyway
pretty disruptive no I'd like that not
she exits her kitchen takes five steps
and lands in that you know it's not
boring yeah but but I can explain to
them yeah you know so when I done when
I'm making the movie I explained to them
how I see somebody getting from one
place to the next or why the front door
has to have a window next to it because
there's the scene where you know Steve
Martin and father the bride's looking
out the window he's watching the guy
pull up all he drove too fast you know I
have to have a window on this scene
where he was standing when the kid
drives up it's just basic stuff like but
you'd be amazed at what people miss
mm-hmm and then what about you know the
quad quad often you go to sort of
physical comedy it's always people thing
with yeah and how descriptive is that in
your very very choreographed yeah mm-hmm
it's complicated now another film that
you wrote durable one of the most recent
series that you wrote and produced this
is another of your kind of post-divorce
films yes my poster for experience yes
eimai blue period but it was pretty good
at it so yet again people say you know
is this you are these are these
characters you and would you answer it
in the same way that this is just you're
taking it I was divorced that's the
extent of it and it's not
autobiographical no do you but you know
a divorced person is like a character
that's not in a lot of movies
other than the angry woman at the door
dropping off the kids woman you know
like the real life what's life like when
you're divorced so yeah and again with
this one where it's you know older
people you know you're picking on a
particular type of actor at a
particularly you know an attic kind of
look I mean I know you know by this time
you're wildly successful and presumably
very few people were saying no to you
but did anybody you know did you still
get a sense of well that's
No you know we don't want to see older
people we don't want them those are the
people that didn't make it but you know
the people that make the movie like it
mm-hmm they don't they have their pick
of whatever so if they're gonna they're
gonna say yes to me to make the movie
they're not going to then take it apart
and change it that doesn't happen I
don't find mm-hmm and we surprised at
how successful it was uh I was really
happy a lot of divorced people I don't
know I was very happy but you know I
such great actors you know
Merrill's brilliant and Steve came in
for a secondary part to Alec Baldwin
which was unusual so I mean I thought I
had a shot the actors were so great
that's very very briefly and on the
intern yeah any sense that you were
updating baby-boom uh I thought of it as
a companion piece I did after I finish
making it towards the end yeah not aware
at all why I was making it but it's
absolutely a companion piece I think
yeah it's very business and motherhood
and balancing and but much more modern I
mean between baby boom was 87 this is
2015 it's a new world but some problems
still exist significantly baby boom
she's an employee she's dying yes yes I
never occurred to me to make this girl
an employee she was gonna be the CEO
founder of her own company which I think
JC the Diane character and baby boom
would have done the same if she were a
kid this age today good night to start
with some questions with regards to
writing comedy to be very funny yeah I'm
always advise you just gotta cram in as
many gags per page just like chucking
this many jokes as you can every single
page but I haven't found that's what
someone gives me that advice I'd be
frozen right what do you have any yeah
forget that advice okay
do you have other that's crazy how can
you do that I mean the funniest things
are the most real or they're based in
something that everyone can relate to
right and nobody can relate to five
jokes on a page honestly don't even
worry about it just do what feels
natural to you I asked a second part to
that with regards to adding detail and
she said on the script like yeah but how
they might say the joke have you found
that that may help so how do I make sure
they deliver the line right yeah oh yeah
I'll do every trick I like chalice eyes
the word I want them to hit sometimes
I'll underline it sometimes I'll put dot
that dot before it yeah I wanted to land
right but I know I'm also gonna be there
to help them but if you're not gonna be
there don't worry about it just save
parenthetical just kidding or with with
ease he says or nervously admits or
whatever just say whatever you however
you want to do I do that all the time
for Robert De Niro and for Jack
Nicholson and Meryl Streep I'll give
them parenthetical direction and I know
I'm there I still do it thank you very
much good luck are there any favorites
comedy scripts of other people that you
admire many Tutsi Annie Hall obviously
shampoo I guess that was a comedy ish
drama tragedy everything Billy Wilder's
ever done so many did I laugh I wondered
if you could talk about your
relationship with hands Emma it seems
yeah yeah he seems to do a sound for you
that he won't do for anyone else it
seems and I wondered like how you know
would agree with you cuz I'm the biggest
pain in the ass he's ever met well the
only reason you're really saying that is
because mostly he does Batman and
interstellar and so of course he's not
going to do a romantic theme in any of
those movies and he loves those movies
much more than my kind of movie but
somehow I read I've wrangled him three
times I didn't get him on this movie
because I think he felt well he was
doing Batman
whatever I said somebody said I'm doing
Batman vs Superman I said yes so he said
so I'm not available I said but could
you do it and I said I really I can't do
it and then I would call him a week
later and I'd say are you still doing
Batman and he did an amazing thing on
something's got to give I had a score by
another composer and I really I really
liked that movie iMovie was very special
to me and well we were scoring the film
and I'm in the scoring session and it's
just like breaking out and she was sweat
I just felt the music wasn't right and
the music is the SU writers will know
it's the only thing that's added to the
movie that you don't the only thing that
goes on that you don't make happen you
know if you if the music is wrong the
scene takes a turn and it's just not
right it's just suddenly this scene has
gone from it's become too dramatic or
it's become too sad or it's got to
sloppier it's just the wrong tone so I
was really dying I was I didn't quite
know what to do but at the woman who was
the head of the music for Sony who made
the movie was sitting with me and she
kept looking at me and she kept going
like this I said what are we gonna do
she's I don't know what we're gonna do
then on the last day of scoring she
pulled me aside she said your score I
don't have a lot of respect for the guy
who wrote that score so I feel bad thing
that's where she said this score is
ruining your movie I said I know what
are we gonna do she said I've placed a
call to Hans Zimmer and he's going to
save us and we had to be finished in a
week in one week
the movie was like had to be done so I
never met Hans and I went over to his
place and he said I saw your movie
because she got him a copy of the movie
and he said so I've come up with
something and if you like it I'll do the
whole score and so um as he tells the
story he had his back to me and he was
playing the piano and playing this tune
and he hears sobbing he was afraid to
turn around and so you said he was
playing and he hears me like got to that
point like that you know and so finally
he stopped and he just had his back to
me and he turned around because he
assumed I hated it and I was in horrible
trouble and when I forget what I said he
knows what I said he's told this story
to me a bunch of times but it was like
he was inside my head and I just it's
bringing tears to my eyes now I just
never thought I could have gotten it I
thought it was something had happened to
the movie that I could not fix so he did
it in a weekend basically I moved into
his offices for a week I went to the
wine store to the wine shop and I bought
like a case of wine took it with me the
next day because there's a lot of people
that work with him and we just all I was
still working during the day on the
movie doing other sound work on it and I
would come there every night and they'd
be writing all day and we'd do it on so
we bonded in the best possible way and
then he did two more I think after that
but he wasn't available in this but I
really loved my score of my new movie I
really do it's it's great and I invited
Hans to come see the movie last week but
he couldn't make it I think he probably
felt I was gonna somehow say could you
fix so it was done so I didn't invite
him to what was done done done but I
loved him so I'm sure there's no way you
could like probably there's no way you
could surmise or like give us a telltale
guide of how to be a good writer but if
there any like three tips or three major
things that you would recommend for a
writer to like well it's a comedy drama
comedy and it's about like my
experiences living in a cooperative
housing in Austin Texas so I've been to
Texas and you should go to Austin
because it's amazing yeah but no I'm
just thinking like well you're already
fit rule number one for me which is to
really write something that's you does
that happen to you hmm that's oh that's
the best thing and then you know just
really uh sounds obvious and like your
mother talking but I mean work really
hard at it I think a lot of young
writers think well they're gonna give me
notes anyway so I'm not really gonna fix
this part forget that give yourself
every possible note you can give
yourself really beat yourself up if you
have to really push yourself as hard as
you can
because they're only gonna read it once
you know with terms of screen
screenplays when you hand one in you you
know show it to a studio they're not
gonna read your next draft you've one
shot with these people
so it's too late then to say I knew I
should have fixed that scene where they
fix it before you show it to anybody so
there's two months does let me just ask
you one final thing your daughter has
written a screenplay yes several um when
she when she started to write when you
thought she was going to be writing does
your heart sink or did it always re with
her choice no sword not no I recommend
writing do you like writing do you happy
writer yes but you know what worries me
about her and all of you is this is such
a different time because the last 35
years you could make movies about people
this movie the intern was very hard to
get made you know for me it was hard to
get made and I've had had successes so
there was a track record there they
could look at and feel good about it was
still really hard to get me so I I worry
about her because I worry about the
climate and the landscape you know of
the movie business and are they but but
I'm I think with my movie getting made
you know and I know a couple other
people have gotten movies made that are
not superhero movies you know whatever
maybe the pendulum is swinging back in
the direction of human beings and human
stories comedies about adults so good
that's the only can't worry about with
her I don't worry about her I worry
about will she be able to get her work
you know will happen for her because the
movie business is not embracing the kind
of work she wants to do mm-hmm
thank you to all of you for your
questions but most of all thank you of
course the one dies fast we were in this
production office in in Dublin and I I
went upstairs and I borrowed somebody's
computer and I wrote the scene in
probably 30 minutes you have to be a
team you know and that for me is one of
the most exciting things about being a
part of a film is the teamwork that
involves everybody
you